this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody you're damn
right they do every little thing you
think that's means every little thing
you sing that to me every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh I bet
that you'll be fine without it
[Music]
well hello Chicago
hey y'all let's record a podcast by the
way since we refused to clutter our
podcast with any advertisements also our
website you can always support us none
of the money goes to us but it goes to
we're building the podcast in film
studio none of the money will go to me
and Ryan over at patreon.com slash the
minimalist you can support the podcast
on a per episode basis if you feel so
inclined we've got some questions here
so Ryan and I will start with our
long-winded answers and we'll work our
way toward a lightning round we've been
doing a little bit different while we're
on the road during the lightning round
usually Ryan and I will give back
tweeted back and forth tweetable answers
we've had a week to craft but now we
have like seven seconds and so we've
turned it into a rap battle without
rapping I think you'll see what I mean
in a little bit we'll go ahead and get
started give us your name where you're
from and what your question is hopefully
in that order hello howdy my name is
rocío from a little village and i just
want to say thank you for coming to
Chicago you guys are awesome you're
awesome thanks for being here thanks for
coming up to support it oh by the way
we're recording this my name's Joshua
fields Melbourne man we can we back
pedal down because he's gone you got
this
give them your name this is Ryan
Nicodemus cities and gentlemen and
together we are the minimalism live in
Chicago
there we go
sean is going to have to figure out how
to edit all of this but thank goodness
for shock sorry go ahead
so I've watched your documentaries I've
listened to your podcast I've read your
book your message resonate I've gone
through the process of trying to get rid
of the clutter at home it's those work
in progress I'm working on it
my question to you is this how do you
guys deal with collision so at home I
feel like it took a year to get my
husband and my four-year-old on board
with minimizing the things that we've
drawn our self with and that took a year
and how'd you do it uh baby says yeah
it's um so what kind of baby says so
so you were you started simplifying
first right you didn't start getting rid
of their things first right we have
people come to us sometimes they're like
I just started with my husband stuff and
man that divorce was really hard and so
I'm glad to hear that you so you started
small and and how did you even introduce
the concept to them this is always
interesting to me well the way that I
introduced the suit my husband was
biking creamy well that's one strategy
once one say I started account I was
doing the dishes and I started to count
the number of cups that were piled on in
the sink and a colonnade 23 cups 23 cups
that most of them were my husband's I
mean some of them are ours and my
daughters I mean sure I said my
daughters yeah and it took about six
months to convince them like we should
all have only two cups okay and that way
I only have to want a wash of six cups
per cycle
what was it was there a straw that broke
the camel's back there or was it just
like sheer stick-to-itiveness pushing
through no I didn't want to wash 23 well
let me ask you this I think that's
actually really important so the benefit
for you is that you wouldn't have to
wash 23 cups but was that the same
benefit of your husband I hope you I do
the dishes in our house Beck's was right
over here and she does the cooking I did
I figured I wouldn't mention her till
the end but this is the perfect
opportunity and yes so she's sort of in
a box like like Juliet or something
movie you don't know Rebecca she runs a
great website called minimal Wellness
and and so I do the dishes in our house
and I I wouldn't want to wash 23 cups
either and so that would be the benefit
for me but that same benefit now that
we're together wouldn't was would not
resonate with vexes much she's like I
don't care if you watched 23 cups what's
the big so you so what was the benefit
for your husband I guess is what I'm
asking I have your wife yeah but but my
question how do you deal with collision
so in the workplace I'm trying to
simplify things I'm trying to simplify
things by challenging things what are
you trying to simplify in the workplace
everything okay
where are you starting well I mean
everything it's the excessive emails the
excessive meetings the excessive
notifications and this expectation of
rushing through everything to get to the
next thing and reacting to everything
and I feel like that's perceived as like
you're not pulling your weight or you're
not a team player or you don't want to
contribute to our growth and I'm finding
it challenging to deal with that and I
feel like it's a collision and I'm
curious if you've experienced that oh
yeah I imagine oh yeah so that that word
is a great word to use it's a perfect
metaphor collision and in fact I'm gonna
take it a step farther so if if I were
to get into a fender bender out front
right like I'm from driving and and and
maybe the the guy behind me is texting
and not paying attention he Rams into my
bumper right that's a collision right
and hopefully I'm going to be okay with
a hit me at two miles an hour and I
didn't get whiplash for whatever reason
and
okay you're probably not going to change
much you're not going to be too paranoid
not much is going to change but if you
get into a a serious car crash a car
accident like Ryan did we got three
years ago this kid ran him off the road
and accidentally but like it was it was
snowy in Montana
and and just rammed him off the highway
and car rolled several times and if you
didn't have a seatbelt on he'd be dead
that's a serious crash and when you
experience a crash in your life for me I
mentioned earlier you know my mom died
my marriage ended both in the same month
that was like getting hit twice in the
same month right and from there you
could you have two decisions after a
crash because that pain is going to make
you go one of two ways it's going to
make you course correct and start to
change everything and I'm grateful to
that's the that's what I did at the time
I stumbled across minimalism right at
the right time for me and the other
thing is you can spiral downward into
despair now for some people that
manifests into alcoholism or drug
addiction or passive activities you know
just being lazy whatever maybe that
spiral is the other way and I think the
the inciting incident has to be big
enough first meaning the person needs to
feel enough pain to associate pleasure
in changing and so for me I felt enough
pain I went back and looked at my own
life took that inventory and said oh
like before my life was a six out of ten
it was just comfortable enough to not
make any real changes in my life
it wasn't outstanding all the time now
don't get me wrong I'm not happy all the
time right now that's called being manic
and I'm not recommending that to anyone
there's medication for it but but what I
am what I am saying is that it's not
about being happy now I am happier than
I was before because my life is
appreciably better
I realized that six out of ten wasn't
actually at six I was pretending I was
out of six and really my life was a two
or three it was a certain level of
comfort so good enough that I don't want
to I don't wanna have to change because
I might lose some of my comfort and so
we get stuck in these patterns these
patterns that we think are comfortable
and so then we get into work and we
start spending all of our time reacting
responding you get 250 emails a day in
the corporate world and then it bleeds
over into our personal life as well
in fact there's very little work-life
balance
I'm okay with that if that's what you
sign up for intentionally but but I was
given a blackberry back in my corporate
days before the BlackBerry phones not
like the fruit but the actual that's the
BlackBerry and they said here this is
going to save you one to two hours a day
of productivity it did the exact
opposite it added additional work
knowledge because I had to start being
more and more and more reactive and that
is where the pain came in for me I
realized like oh this is I'm not
actually doing anything meaningful
there's a deep work here this doesn't
align with the person I want to be I'm
constantly neuro Singh over stuff that
doesn't really matter in order to change
that I need to make sure that I
experience this pain and and so how do
you deal with collision you turn the
collision into a crash and what I mean
by that is that the people also need to
experience the pain the same way that
your husband experienced the pain of oh
I don't have a happy wife the benefit of
me isn't look at the dishes is the
benefit for me is if you're not happy
I'm not happy when Beck's is upset oh my
god like I'll do anything I'll jump up
and down or whatever I can do to make
her happy I will go out of my way to do
that if it's within my power and your
husband felt the same way for you he was
like well I in order to change it's like
it's not important to me but it's
important to you and because it's
important to you it's important to me
and that's when you get that leverage
and so I think you got to turn that the
gender bender into
into a car crash the other thing you can
do is just make the changes yourself
like Ryan and I got rid of social media
on our phones recently we're not off
social media but we decided hey I'm
going to take this off my phone so I can
be more in the moment and less twitchy
for that that device all the time and in
doing that it allowed me to say here's
the benefit for me and we've had so many
people come to us on this tour and said
I quit social media my phone too because
of you and it's not like an original
idea or anything but they saw the
benefits in us and they're willing to
make the change that's my short answer
was a good answer thank you oh yeah I
would echo what Josh said finding what
the benefits are going to be for your
company and positioning positioning it
that way like if I went to my boss on
this course it's easy for me to say like
you know from the outside looking in but
you know I'm trying for myself in your
shoes if I went to my boss and I said
hey I would like to have about half as
many of the emails and if they responded
to me and said well you're not a team
player that sounds like you know non
team player talk I would I would turn it
around I'd say no no I want to have half
the emails because I am a team player
and I would rather do more constructive
things with my time and add more value
to this company then reading you know
the latest update or whatever it may be
so I think there are ways you could
certainly turn that around a little bit
I remember Josh like when when I said
Josh was happy like you know they hadn't
been that happy and so long it was I
just remember noticing like all these
small changes in him the first change
was after he had split up with his wife
he had to move in to a new apartment and
Josh just he loves to make me move
things we used to like he like literally
we would joke around he called me I
would be like hey are you ready for Ryan
and Josh move heavy
season four so I'm helping to move into
his apartment and there is a wall mount
for a TV that is already installed in
this apartment that he got and that was
like one thing that Josh and I
constantly would always like brag about
oh man I got the latest TV technology I
you know I get my TVs bigger than your
yeah I don't know what Freud would say
about that but but yeah it was always
who at the best technology whose TV was
bigger how many TVs that you have I mean
it was like this really stupid like you
know symbol that we would use to like
kind of compare each other's lives to so
as soon as I fell that mount I'm like
dude TV are you gonna get man like how
how big is it gonna be are you gonna get
that new DLP whatever you know
technology was out at the time and he
was like you know I don't know if I'm
gonna get a TV and I just kind of like
brushed it off I was like well when he's
gonna get a TV um
months passed and like no TV and I never
really like questions that much but then
the one thing that really stood out to
me and this is where I knew something
had changed it was was Christmas Eve uh
Josh was on a date and he he was telling
me the story about how he's sitting
there with his date and our boss is
calling him and he's like you know I
ignored the call and he calls me back
it's like 6:00 or 6:30 at night and I
ignore the call again and he just kept
calling me and calling so you know Josh
picks up the phone and it was our boss
and he's like hey man he's like where
where are your sales numbers at right
now how much have your stores sold I
mean this was Christmas Eve so Christmas
Eve in retail is like the second busiest
day it's where you make like the Black
Friday you make the most money Christmas
Eve is when you make the the second most
money during that whole season um
Josh responded to him and said I don't
know
I don't know what where my stores are at
right now he's like what do you mean
what do you our boss like what do you
what do you mean you don't know I mean
are my boss wants those numbers you need
to have those numbers what is wrong with
you why don't you know those numbers and
Josh said dawn I'm on a date right now
it's 6:30 at night the stores are going
to close in an hour and a half what
you're asking of me right now is
unreasonable and like that just floored
our boss I mean it was like almost
sacrilegious to say anything like that
and you know the reason why Josh could
get away with that it's because he added
so much value to that company that at
the end of the day our pasca look in the
mirror and go you know what maybe it is
a little unreasonable because Josh just
so many other things that maybe what he
was asking wasn't reasonable so I guess
what I'm saying is that you might like
that I never would have had the cojones
to talk to our boss like that I mean I'm
surprised Josh did but but but looking
back I'm like I wish I would have
because I was adding a lot of value to
the company and it wouldn't have been
inappropriate for me to ask questions or
try to set different expectations so at
the end of the day like if you are
valuable to your company if you if you
give them way more than what they pay
you for it is totally appropriate to ask
questions like how can I reduce my email
or how can i how can I you know turn my
phone off at seven o'clock at night
whatever it is that you're trying to
implement and you don't just give them a
laundry list of stuff like pick the one
or two things that really stands out to
you that you really want to change but I
promise you and you know me who is hired
and fired lots of people I can tell you
like the people who added the most value
to my team they got away with murder and
like the people who didn't do well on my
team and they were just kind of slacking
I mean I always looked for an excuse
to work them out right so yeah I'm just
reiterating like if you are adding value
to your company then it's totally
appropriate for you to set different
expectations thank you hello what's your
name my name is Jonah and from Oakland I
don't have a question I just want to
thank you I just want to thank you from
the bottom of my heart I really don't
have a question you're very brave in
speaking your truth and following your
own path and you've changed a lot of
lives as you know but there's a lot of
odd ducks out there like I know you're
bringing this information to a lot of
people who've never heard it before but
there are lots of us out there who have
felt inclined to follow this way of life
and there's a lot of cultural resistance
so for all the odd ducks out there thank
you thank you so much for now thank you
Wow
you know if it was if it was just you
that got anything out of this whole
thing like that would make it worth it
you know it doesn't matter like how many
retweets we get or how many social media
followers we have like that right there
is why we do it
hi father Karen I'm originally from New
York hi later like the city upstate or
the city
Long Island okay um so I just found out
about you guys a few weeks ago and I
immediately have listened to hours and
hours of podcast I just watched a
documentary about the dead mice a book
for my dad and for me and he's a hoarder
unfortunately good cleaner one because
my mom doesn't let him be a full-blown
hoarder but the point is I realized
others well organized order yeah to a
degree our living room looks great his
office was horrendous so it's one of
those situations but I have always had a
lot of clutter and I've become more
cognizant of it as an adult as I moving
with my fiance and I'm just trying to
really get rid of all the garbage and
all the excess and what I'm running into
now is I'm getting rid of things and I'm
going to start next month and do the 30
day challenge and I already have gotten
rid of a lot but I'm really stressed out
because I don't have a car and I'm in an
apartment building I can't do a garage
sale and there's so many things I feel
like well this could you know I have all
these extra dog toys my dog does not
need that many you know what this I
could bring to a shelter and all these
pens and notebooks I could bring to a
school and and this food I could bring
to a soup kitchen I volunteered and
there's just so many things I want to
give to different places and it's
bothering me now because I have you know
half a room filled with boxes but I'm
not done and I just I feel like there's
got to be a logistical II better way to
get this off my hands yeah definitely so
so do you know anyone with a car I do I
do but I feel like I'm gonna keep going
and it's it's you know you know so much
time and energy yeah no I agree with
that and it's going to take energy
especially at first because you don't
have a lot of momentum that first none
of us do right when you when you're
first getting started it's like it's
pushing the boulder uphill right you
have any any momentum and so it's going
to be difficult at first once you get
that momentum as I said earlier like
what if I got rid of one item a day for
30 days I mean
last year like one item I got this and
this and this and what about that oh my
god when's the last time we're worth
that you know it's like a oversized
orange sweatshirt with tassels and
you're like well when am i won
I didn't did I ever wear that until like
you you realized really quickly like oh
my god like none of this stuff is
actually adding much value to my life
and so I would I would start to plan it
out and schedule it right now I mean you
could you could rent a car you could get
a friend has a car you could you could
rent a u-haul for a day and just put all
the stuff in it you're going to get rid
of you have a lot of options
I think the key step here is for you to
take action which you're starting to
right now but a lot of these hurdles
that we put up in our way like I don't
have a car
they are imaginary hurdles they're not
actual I mean they feel like hurdles to
us right now but you look in the
rearview and you're like oh yeah there
were seventeen different solutions there
are a dozen people here tonight who
would who would let you use their car
for an evening yeah and and so what I'll
say is quite often having those people
there to support you is is really
important so we a few years ago Ryan and
I went on this crazy 100 city tour yeah
we were in Chicago at one point and we
used people used to call it goes after
the event they'd say you know it's great
that you're here for a night but now
you're leaving and how do I connect with
like-minded people locally and I would
just sort of stare at them blankly and
blink a few times I didn't have a good
answer and so Ryan and I and 2014 we
created something called minimalist org
it's free local meetup groups in 100
different cities and Chicago is one of
them and they meet once a month so you
can surround yourself with supportive
open-minded people but not always like
minded but they tend to be open-minded
have similar values to you even if they
have different beliefs and find once you
do that you'll find if there's 20 people
there you'll find 20 creative ways to
start to tackle your problem in
particular and if I were in your shoes
I'd find someone had a car and I would
get rid of as much stuff as I could fit
into their car and then I would do it
again
tomorrow or next weekend or whatever
it's on my calendar first step put it on
your calendar block off those hours
don't let anyone else touch those hours
say no to everyone else so you can say
yes to let him go yeah I would I would
totally agree with you and Josh like it
is going to take a lot of time and a lot
of energy you know like often we we
mistaken the word simple with easy and
like simple is not easy in fact easy is
just leaving them things in the boxes in
your room that's the easy thing to do so
it is it is going to take time and it is
going to take some energy but yeah you
have to have a plan and you've got to
start not just taking action on that
plan but taking massive action taking
action is like you go sit in your seat
and schedule out a day to get rid of
some stuff like that's action massive
action is actually doing it Massa Mac
action is borrowing that car filling it
with the stuff and then and then
dropping it off and I'll tell you here
in Chicago you probably got a service
out there where people will come and
pick up your stuff I mean in Missoula
Montana with 67,000 people we've got the
donation warehouse there that they will
literally come and pick up anything that
you have to donate so like junk
like almost anything broken lamps I mean
anything yeah almost anything red
underwear but uh but yeah I mean it's
Missoula Montana has a service like that
I am positive that Chicago has a service
like that it's not several services so
there are certainly different ways to
tackle it there's no doubt about it
um I'll tell you when I had like you
know within all those boxes or it's kind
of like you're like I know there's some
stuff in there that it's definitely a
mixture there's things I've totally
forgot I had when I'm doing this and
there's things
every time I look at it I'm like I've
decided I don't need it and I've waited
time and I still have decided I don't
need it so it's definitely a mixture
yeah I would um I had those same type of
boxes like I knew kind of what was in
some of those sealed up boxes but wasn't
sure exactly what the image where he was
of every single box um when I had a
garage sale like I sold stuff like I
started selling I started opening up the
boxes I'm like oh man a price stuff out
individual and I'm like you know what
I'm just I'm not even gonna like open
these boxes up because I know what I
knew like as soon as I open up the boxes
I feel like oh here's this half packet
of spaghetti noodles I've I like
spaghetti I might eat that one day like
I just knew I would start having that
you know just in case syndrome and like
flinching to keeps up so I just like
literally had mystery boxes that I would
set like I think I had you know six of
them and I literally did like one two
three four five six dollars on each one
and then it's funny cos like the most
expensive box had all the leftover like
half bags of flour half a box of
spaghetti noodles and I felt so bad for
the guy that got it I was like dude I
was like Elena's have it he's like no no
no no no that was like eighty-six he's
like this is great man like we were
gonna have spaghetti tonight like no
this is perfect
I mean it was really really I mean he
was so excited about something that was
very much not exciting but you could
certainly do that sell those bad boys on
Craigslist trying to find you every
single possession that you want to get
rid of so it's great that you have these
boxes you know what you want to get rid
of them finding finding somewhere or
finding a home for every single one of
those possessions like you've got to be
able to weigh out like what is what is
your time worth um my like big-screen TV
that I sold I sold for like 200 bucks
that was worth my time the cellphones I
had that were four years old that you
know were once worth 400 bucks I would
never be able to recoup 400 dollars let
alone 20 bucks and then trying to sell a
cell phone for $20 on Craigslist or an
eBay that is four years old was not
worth my time like a lot of that stuff
had to look at his son cost and I went
and donated it and I let
the professionals find those places a
good home whether it was like in Ohio we
had oh it was a like a like a battered
wise foundation where they would take
those cell phones like tournament of
prepays and like given the people in
need um but you know giving your stuff
to Goodwill or a donation place they
make it their job to find it a good home
and that is their job that's exactly
what they're there for
so there's definitely a few ways to
approach it but yeah you've got to take
that massive action to make it happen
for sure thank you very much thank you
hello hello what's your name my name is
Lindsey and I'm from Naperville make
immediate welcome thank you very much
I'm so excited to be here but I just
want to say first I'm so proud of both
of you just for how far you guys have
come and your backgrounds and everything
I can relate so much thank you and I
just want to thank you for being so
transparent about your backgrounds too
and just sharing that with your
followers because I think it's really
inspiring so thank you for that
more please um so just to start I think
that my question is mostly directed at
Ryan so I feel like when I was reading
your book with Josh like I think the
path in your passion was a lot more
obvious for you to kind of step away
from be like you know what this was
something I've been wanting to do for a
really long time and like I'm just going
to commit you know not saying it was
easy at all but just to say Ryan earlier
you made a really good point in saying
like you were just up against the grind
you were working so hard and you didn't
often take time to step back and think
about like what am i passionate about so
I'm curious like what are some of the
questions that you asked yourself and
how did you build the confidence to
actually take action on following that
path because there's a lot of people I
think that haven't taken the time to
think about it or know it's a great
question so like how do you figure out
what you're passionate about I guess
like where it started for me um I
started to think about what I liked
about my my current corporate job that I
had at the time and my most favorite
part of the job
it was like taking that employee that I
was getting ready to fire because they
were the worst sales person on my team
and I would talk to them and mentor them
and coach them and you know two months
later they're getting Employee of the
Month like making that how I should say
helping someone make a shift like that
like that really really just made me
feel good I mean is it's it's funny like
you know Josh and I we love to give but
when you give you still get something
back from it um but so I you know I
guess I kind of started there in fact
when I finally was able to leave my job
although I got laid off I didn't I did
not quit like Josh did yeah but but but
I thought I did prepare you know over
the last year year and a half or before
I got laid off like I had prepared for
that moment in fact I went to my boss a
month before I got laid off
and he knew about the website I mean he
was always giving me crap for it like
you know if you raised time and he's
like well you're a minimalist you don't
need this raise do you know who yeah
when you call yourselves the minimalist
everything you do is just steeped in
irony yeah yeah so yeah so I sat him
down I'm like hey man um you know that
I'm not going to be here forever like
you know that like I eventually want to
do something else and I'm just wondering
if I'd left this role who would you
replace me with and he thought about it
for a second and he was like you know
what he's like he did a really good job
of you know building this this channel
and in the stores like I basically this
position I had was created to basically
sell small office home office business
sales out of telecommunications retail
stores and that's the most boring
sentence of the whole night um
but but a rounded like a full body when
great is that well my point is is that I
had I had the right people in the right
places it was running himself and he was
like you know you did a pretty good job
setting this up he's like I don't think
I would I don't think I would flow your
position if you left and I'm like yeah
that's an interesting thought isn't it
and then a month later they're like hey
Ryan can you meet me in you know room
217 we're like I mean that's where we
laid everybody off I can only assume
that's where it was right across from a
chars office like like alright man I'll
see you there um but uh our way he's me
we've got the best part the day this
happened it was on his boss's birthday
and so Ryan shows up a like this really
nice bottle of like whiskey and and like
several different birthday gifts that
are wrapped like pristinely yeah he was
a vodka drinker in a cigar smoker there
you go and I bought him like being
nicest I knew I was getting laid off so
I just could be like here have some
cigars you're gonna need to relax way
more than me but I got him like super
nice box of cigars and it was funny
because I was like it's your birthday
today right he's like yeah man I was
like man you're laying people off on
your birthday that sucks um so so anyway
I got laid off and a couple months later
Josh had started his writing class and I
knew that I was interested in coaching
and mentoring um I don't know what you
would call it whatever it is don't call
me a life coach because like they have
way more experience than I do but I was
like you know what it like I think I
want to try I think I want to try this
coaching thing out so we put it up on
the website and I just you know by the
seat of my pants just started mentoring
people and it turned out to be really
really awesome and I still do that today
and I love it i absolutely do love it
and i'll tell you i didn't just like
start out with this I'm going to like
coach people and I'm passionate about
this I'm going to be passionate about it
for the rest of my life it was an
interest that I had I knew I liked it
and I pursued it and I cultivated it and
it certainly is a passion now and the
same thing with snowboarding I mean
every every year I'm still like getting
better and better every year um I just
like dread the day when I'm like you
know 60 or something and I'm like I know
eventually I can hit snowboard the rest
of my life but but as long as I can
continue to improve each year like I
feel like I still have that like I'm
going to live to want to be 150 feeling
but but it's time that was snowboarding
it's like that is a something that I was
interested in and I started to cultivate
that passion I continue to cultivate
that so I guess what I would what I
would say is its if you're someone out
there who you don't have like one thing
that you're passionate about that's okay
first off like we're not born to be
passionate about one thing Josh was not
born to be a writer I was not born to be
a mentor I mean these are things that we
have cultivated over years of investment
time massive action so what I would say
is pick one thing that you're interested
in and then start to put the time and
invest in that thing to to cultivate the
passion and you know what you may two
years from now you might let's say you
wanted to start writing in two years
from now you're like you know like I've
written I wrote that book and I've been
writing this blog and you know what like
I'm just not this is not this is a more
net negative than them as a positive I'm
not really passionate about writing like
and that's okay you can be passionate
about a lot of things if you've got like
five interests and you don't know where
to start then fold them up and put them
in a hat and then just pick one out and
start with that like that that is that
is a good technique but you do have to
choose one thing to start cultivating us
as a passion for sure you know I'll just
add to that real quick if you have to if
you expect if you have five things or
ten things whatever find two of them
they really just stand out for whatever
reason maybe they're radically different
and then one PES one sales grab a coin
flip the coin but don't look at it and
think about which side you hope it lands
on and that's that's where you should go
yeah thank you thank you good all right
before we move on for those of you
listening to this at home if you have a
comment or tip for anyone who asked us a
question today you can call us up leave
us a voicemail for zero six two one nine
at seven eight three nine or you can
actually send us a voice memo from your
phone now podcast at the minimalists
comm and we will air our favorite
comments and tips on future episodes
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalist lightening round yeah we are
on social media Twitter Instagram
Facebook at the minimalist and although
we don't have in our phone thankfully we
have a wonderful jessica williams who
runs our social media cache she's always
finding great stuff and we're always
answering her is she around here
somewhere
yeah look at her she's in the other
balcony Jessica Williams ladies and
gentlemen she does the speaking of
curation she does a great job of
curating our I mean not just our like
Facebook feed or whatever because we're
constantly asking like does this add
value the thing we don't want to do is
add to the noise and if we ever do
anything that we feel would be a net
negative to you or even neutral I'm not
going to waste your time with us so it's
always the thing I just when I were
talking another day at lunch she's like
you know you guys have never asked me
about like post engagement or how many
retweets something has gotten but we do
ask different questions we're asking
like before you tweet this out does it
add value and and so that's what we try
to do with any of these different
channels is find a way to best
communicate and sometimes it still is
social media at least for now and so we
usually have a week to answer these
questions we write them down and and we
battle back and forth vigorously but now
we have a few seconds you can ask a
regular
question we hope to give you a condensed
answer that is less than 140 characters
that you can share on your social media
platform of choice by the way if you're
sharing tonight you can use hashtag less
is now for any of the photos of stuff
will retweet and we share all of our
favorites howdy
what's your name my name is Tammy hitter
and I'm born and raised in California
but I currently live in South Carolina
first I want to say thank you for saying
no to other things so you can say yes to
this and they say that question and
congratulations on all your success in
your growth in just everything that you
give everybody every day listening to
your work my question is well first let
me say this I feel like trying to adapt
minimalism for my life or my lifestyle I
feel like I've been able to learn some
things that myself that I didn't know
before and accept some things my
question to you both is what because
clean up the clutter for clarity and I
stopped seeing minimalism what have you
learned and what do you now see about
yourself that you weren't able to before
you want me to start if you got one yeah
I've got a nice 51 oh go for min I was
going to ramble a little bit I've like
some old tweetable
well I'll ramble a little bit but then
I've got to wrapped up with a bow here I
learned this especially after minimalism
because I was not a very patient person
before I was anxious and I'm still it ID
fault is anxiety that resonate with
anyone
and the other half of the room is like
Ryan and he like thrives under pressure
right and and so I learned that once I
walked away from that like many of the
things I thought were so important
weren't important not just weren't that
important they weren't important at all
like the things that word
I know roast over that kept me up late
at night my boss called me one in the
sales numbers the team underperforming
the retail store opened two minutes late
whatever it was I look back now and it's
nothing it literally means nothing to me
and I can pay especially since becoming
a parent which I never I never intended
to do and but I met an awesome person
and she had a one-year-old and so I
jumped in all the way and I think the
thing that I I've learned most is here's
my short answer for you patience is a
choice I wish I would have known that
when I was 18 or 25 or 27 and stressed
out of online patience is a choice by
the way you get to vote on on whose
answers better so that was crickets no
it was just they were contemplating um
man I'll tell you the first lesson I
learned when I was like looking at all
that stuff in my boxes packed in there I
was just like wow if I had not spent
tens of thousands of dollars on these
things like I could have a savings
account right now I wouldn't have I'd
have much less debt and it's funny cuz
like if you were to ask me what my
priorities were I would have said well
retiring early that's one of my
priorities but like I had no savings
account that's
doesn't really work that equation
definitely does not work so I guess you
know what I would say my short answer
would be my priorities aren't what I say
they are it's what I actually do thank
you yeah
I think from the quiet response we tied
on that first one so we'll have to do
and what we'll do one more for sure and
then we'll see where we stand after that
and we'll go from there
howdy hi I'm Sammy I remember I'm
Chicago
thanks for coming out thanks for all the
applause and cheering I really
appreciate it yeah I really I have lost
100 pounds in the last four years
congratulations yeah that's awesome whoo
January I found your minimalist
documentary I watched it three times
before I was like wow holy [ __ ] have any
of you seen the documentary so we have a
guest here tonight do you like the way
our website looks at all yes yeah so
there's no sidebar there's no banners
there's no clutter right
it seems apropos well Jeff Harris and
his team over inspired me they're in
charge of all of our web development
design everything that makes it all look
beautiful and I think he's way up here
that's gonna wake up he's really tall
he's actually not in the balcony and
he's just standing right now but they're
really great and he is also one of the
producers on our documentary as well and
they help us out a ton and we honestly
we couldn't literally couldn't do many
of the things that we do now because if
we didn't have such an awesome team
sorry to derail you lots under pounds
watch your documentary start listen to
your podcast January I purged all of my
just in case fat clothes you know maybe
I would gain 50 pounds no I'm okay No so
I purge that hurts my possession started
following the minimalist are the
wellness blog amazing I have a lot of
food allergies soy lactose gluten free
low glycemic so it's hard for me to like
eat food you're describing my diet
exactly it's very hard um but besides
that taking a lot away from your
documentary and your podcast that I've
listened to daily I am a photographer
here in Chicago and I'm having a hard
time trying to balance work life and
life in general I'm sick and tired of
being on my goddamn phone
I got this new iPhone 7 my [ __ ] my
phone died and it broke and I'm like
alright I'll pay I'll get the iPhone 7
but it's like this new shiny thing but I
just want to be away from it but I
worked through a studio that requires me
to answer emails like I have to within
10 minutes respond
10 30 minutes respond to if I can accept
this job or not through this photography
studio I can't handle any more I just
don't want my phone anymore
so how do you guys balance that I mean I
don't have a social media person that
can you know post on my behalf and like
you look at her she's doing photos you
know I can't do that I didn't for 35
years either so I told it totally
resonate something and so I'm just I
wanted to be able that like just leave
my phone away and not have an Apple
watch and that you know I have a Fitbit
that tells me my text messages but I
turn my notifications off because I
don't want to be bothered with that [ __ ]
anyways but how do you you know I mean
you have somebody that posts on your
behalf but you know and I've I only have
Facebook and Instagram and Facebook as
the show is to tell my mom and dad that
I'm still alive I don't really post
anything but it's like a she's online
she's still she's still kicking she's so
good
but Instagram it's been difficult
they're banning posts of people trying
to like you know hashtag this and this
this is miss and to promote their photos
and all that stuff and it's becoming
hard and hard to find inspiration
I really value what I really had fun joy
out of Instagram but recently it's been
kind of a slow decline so how do you
guys balance that like I want to step
away from my phone but yet I'm trying to
be a businesswoman and tried to promote
my business as a photographer here in
Chicago sure man I've got like three
pithy answers and also all work this so
here's the thing that I'll tell you
about this so I still use social media
all the time a lot of the comments you
see on our Twitter and Instagram and and
Facebook and post as I get to go on
whenever I want now I don't know ever
feel tethered to it and so every time I
go there I was on there this morning I
mean I can't help get a foot get up
really early like I went to bed at like
I don't know after 1:00 a.m. and woke up
at 4:30 and and I I tend to go to bed
way earlier than that typically but when
I got up I'm like I am going to do my
writing and then I'm going to do handle
a few other things and oh let me spend
20 minutes just responding to people
let's see what they thought about the
event last night and so I get on there
respond to people respond to some people
on our patreon page and and I interact
with people but I get to do it on my
time and that's the difference what what
is driving you crazy may not be the tool
it's the way the tools being used damn
that was that was pity I've got I've got
two more for you one is the things that
add value to your life today may not add
value to your life tomorrow and
Instagram is a prime example that you
may have gotten value from that a month
ago a year ago whatever you may not
continue to get the same value from that
thing you know Ella's turning for this
month and and I pretty sure that the toy
she's playing with now she won't be
playing with twenty years from now and
if so then we'll have a different
conversation and and that's because we
we grow out of certain things and you
may not be that you grow out of having
Instagram on your phone right now but
maybe you grow out of the way that you
use it and so that that's my second 50
thing the the third thing is you
mentioned the battery area the phone
dying and it reminded me that like my
battery would constantly die all the
time because I was always scrolling
right like scrolling and checking and
and and and tweeting and and yuck
yakking and whatever you all do these
days and what I learned was the third
thing if your phone is always getting
ready to die it's probably not your
phone that has a problem man I was I was
like right there with you with the
social media stuff especially like I
really like to interact with the the
minimalist or groups I mean it's just
yeah it's fun to go on there and you
know like someone's comment or something
and they're like oh my god Ryan like my
my comment and I'm just like so happy I
can make someone you know happy by doing
that stuff well it got to a point where
I was good about all right hold on real
quick I found out at a year in after run
the website Ryan wasn't following me on
Twitter it was not on purpose one point
one day was the most awkward
conversation we have ever had I'm like
dude do you realize you don't I mean I
felt so small as soon as you say
something out loud you're like what a
[ __ ] I am like a notice if you don't
follow me on Twitter I'm like yeah I do
but we have you tighten tweet all the
tweets what are you talking about we
have each other's password so I just
logged in and followed me yeah um but I
swear I was getting 200 200
notifications so Josh and I we deleted
the social media apps off of our phone
and having to log into Facebook I don't
I just I hate I always hate going to it
from my computer which is Facebook gets
yeah man like the little messages the
direct messages it's like you either
have to give them all your information
and download the app or like you have
go on the computer and that's a total
aside but uh there's sneaky little
little folks um but I was that if we
were on the first wave like we were in
Pittsburgh and I'm like stressing out
about I gotta log into Facebook I
haven't checked it in the day and a half
I've got like 400 notifications sitting
there I just know it and all of a sudden
I was like wait a minute what would
happen if I just like deactivated my
personal Facebook account I'm like I
don't think anything would really happen
that negatively and I actually held on
my personal Facebook account it was at
first because I wanted you know my mom
to know that I was still you know alive
and kick'n and um and yeah I talked to
Josh about it and like I totally
deactivated it and you know I'm still
alive can you believe it
yeah and but I guess you know all these
things that we that we put on ourselves
you can look at it like these boulders
that we decide to pick up and we start
like walking down the road or walking up
a hill even and I guess my pit the
answer would be it doesn't matter what
Boulder you're carrying you picked it up
and you can set it down thank you guys
very much thank you
I'm going to apologize the folks in line
we've run out of time for additional
questions but I promise you if you call
on the podcast we'll do our best to
answer those we have to move on to the
added value segment of the show this was
a Ryan and I talked about the things
that have added value to our lives
recently and usually we just crow on
about the latest albums we're listening
to or whatever but since we're in
Chicago we might as well talk about some
local things that add value to our live
Ryan what has been adding value to your
life recently I actually got a written
down to my phone no a sky steal which by
the way how awesome is Scott yeah yeah
he is um we are so lucky to have him on
tour with us right now he was he was
just on the road with Vanessa Carlton
and yeah and that we just happen to be
able to sync up on on this wave of our
tour so yeah give it up for Sky Steel
[Applause]
so when I got back
or when I got here to the to the venue I
go to the green room in disguise like
he's like man he's like can I recommend
something for you to recommend locally
here and I'm like yeah sure what do you
got man he said you know I lost art he
didn't lose he left his laptop charger
in in Brooklyn and he went to the Apple
Store you know to go buy a new charger
and they want like you know after tax
it's almost a hundred bucks for a for a
laptop charger and he said he's like man
I went to this place called free geeks
and he got a charger for like 20 bucks
but what's cool about this place is it's
a non-profit business so all of their
time and energy it's spent into like
fixing computers into getting
comfortable or getting people
comfortable with the different programs
so forth and so on
they even have like different classes
that they will teach you different
things and they do it in different
languages as well so I'm going to steal
Sky's recommendation and yeah if you
need like your laptop fixed or you leave
your laptop charger in Brooklyn and you
need another one oh yeah free geeks it
sounds like a pretty cool place so check
it out sweet
have any of you here been to the sweat
lodge in Chicago there's one person
really all - I see - okay man you've got
to go to the sweat lodge I mean so it's
a Russian bathhouse and so on the first
time I went to a Russian bathhouse I was
in Los Angeles and like I was the
everyone to start walking away speaking
Russian it wasn't the same thing here
there was a lot of that a lot of
tattooed burly men but what I I goes by
the way it's men only - so yeah but
there's actually sort of only true they
have a coaxial ities that is not
adjacent to there but it sits in town as
well if they have a co-ed facility as
well I do a sauna like three times a
week it really helps help my back I have
the worst back of any 35 year old I know
and so I do that but I can tell you that
if you want to experience like crazy
natural euphoria you go from 220 degrees
Fahrenheit to 30 degrees salinated water
repeatedly you know you spend 20 minutes
here in a minute here or two minutes in
the cold water if you can really take it
and it's one of the best experiences
you'll ever have every time I take
someone there though I have got to come
back and do this again and so check it
out is called called the sweat lodge all
right let's move on to the right here
right now so we talked about what's
going on the lives of the minimalist and
right now well we just mentioned sky
we're gonna work you know most people
they back back when musicians used to
sell physical goods only right there
wasn't the whole digital world it's
someone put out a new song it was called
a single a cassette single some of you
remember this and and you would buy the
cassette and it would have like a song
on it and it would be like this
experience you go to the store you'd
have the experience of unwrapping the
thing and you you'd open it up and you
look a little tracklist and the credits
and you read as you listen to the song
well we don't really have that same
experience anymore but sky has been
thinking about how do we how do we make
single and experience again right and so
he came home with a way to pair his new
single with some chocolate that is made
specifically for the song and it's from
a local company here in Chicago called a
come on Josh vote there we got I got it
they get this guy wherever you are so
we're gonna welcome sky feel out Ryan
and I grinning some chocolate while he
plays a song wait do we have there it is
the delicious delicious chocolate un
explain the robot every part of the
whole show he's unwrapping the chocolate
was for people at home there's there's
two pieces of chocolate in here and so
after where Ryan and I will be out there
selling our books
we hope you buy a stack of them no I'm
just kidding actually if you do pick up
a book please minimize it afterward get
it to a local library a friend sale
member someone who give value from it if
you can't afford a book tonight you just
forgot your wallet let me and Ryan buy a
copy for you if you're interested in one
would be happy to pick one up for you
thanks and if you get the opportunity to
support Skye you can buy his new single
and you can have a really good excuse me
some chocolate you have to wait to play
the song because it pairs really nicely
yeah you got to download this song and
put it on and then eat the chocolate and
you have the whole experience
alright so that's not you guys got a
little nervous during this part so I
want to help you with the experience I'm
not going to give you the whole thing
but you guys here's the five steps okay
breathe smell and taste in that in that
order in that order
alright
[Music]
comes to me can't rescue chocolate I
hate mine yeah
that's better than opening a cassette
tape I promise you and it's gone
afterwards so it's like it's the best
kind of consumable I think Scott has a
very limited number of those chocolates
out there if you're interested in
getting one after the show its I don't
know what he charges but he charges
something for them and you want to
support him I know all the proceeds from
anything that he sells tonight goes to
his favorite charity it's the gas fund
for sky to get to Madison Wisconsin they
do really great work anyway what else is
going on with us oh I mentioned the
patreon thing if you want to support us
we are trying to pay Sean a full-time
living wage Pat podcast Sean so you can
just go to patreon.com/scishow do so we
can do more video content creations
meaningful work Jeff is Dave here David
he's not here okay the ammo is gonna I
was going to shout him out anyway so
what we're trying to do is just create
more video because the documentary went
over so well with people it showed
people the minimalism wasn't crazy it
wasn't it wasn't this this radical
lifestyle was much more practical than a
lot of people thought and so we hope to
be able to translate in the video doing
a video version of the podcast and we're
going to do video essays live streams a
bunch of new video work in a new audio
studio as well so if you want help out
with that it's just patreon.com slash
the minimalists be part of the 1% of our
audience that helps out if you can't
afford it to help out that's okay too
because you can just leave us a review
on Apple podcasts and if you do that
this month which is May 2017 the people
listening to this we're donating 10
bucks to a charity of our choice and we
picked a special one for us so did you
know that half the people who have ever
lived on planet Earth have died from
malaria half the people who have ever
lived have died from malaria
and we're trying to help change that a
little bit so the against malaria
foundation estimates it costs about
thirty five hundred bucks to to buy
enough mosquito nets for one person to
save a life over a a lifetime so
mosquito that's only like five bucks but
over a lifetime takes a lot of a lot of
money a lot of nets to save someone's
life so about thirty five hundred
dollars to save a life so for every
three hundred fifty Apple podcast
reviews we we get this month we're
donating ten bucks each so it's $3,500
so if you want to contribute in that way
we can do something cool we can spread
the message to more people but we can
also help some people in need as well so
afterward if you want to whip out your
phone and leave us a review by the way
if any review you want if you want to
leave us five stars we'd love that if
you hate our freaking guts and you're
like I can't believe my wife dragged me
here these guys get in one star that's
okay we'll still give ten bucks for that
as well
I'm going to thank a few people before
we roll out of here tonight I want to
thank David from Live Nation so this is
first time we've ever had like a proper
tour like Ryan and I used to just show
up with coffee houses and people would
show up and that was great but quality
else would get really mad if like 700
people showed up so we have to do this
instead
but Live Nation has been great they've
been promoting the tour and I don't know
where David is here but I'm really
grateful that you're here for the stuff
he's been amazing this is in you but
let's give it up for Thalia Hall as well
yeah
[Applause]
we are doing 40 cities this year and
this is the best venue I've been to so
far most aesthetically pleasing and
beautiful how awesome is this speaking
of that tour if you're listening at home
we are coming into 40 cities and if you
want to find the city nearest you it's
all of North America US and Canada just
go to Les is now dot-com and you can
find all the cities dates theaters
ticket information and most important I
want to thank you for being here tonight
yes it cost you money to get in here and
we're grateful that you paid for that
because it allows us to pay all these
people Ryan I don't make money from
touring but the people that we travel
with they we make sure that they get
paid a good wage and so you didn't just
give up your money though you gave up
your time and your attention
those are your two most precious
resources and we're really grateful that
you decided to come here and spend that
time with us in about 20 minutes or so
we'll be out there and in the lobbying
we'll say hi and get a hug you can get a
book a picture whatever you'd like and
if you leave here with one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for being here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little singing you think that me
every little singing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
every little singing that you got Hey
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grin
oh I bear that you be fine without so
tear your eyes
[Music]